nathan tallenbaum from the bowtie nate  home studio with your most accurate  weather now forecast and welcome  to mother nature's weather buffet we've  literally had a little bit of everything  got a beautiful picture from our camera  on top of the bank of america  looking out to the east you got the 95  freeway there uh you got  clouds and some sunshine the official  numbers for las vegas sit  in we're at 48 that's two degrees cooler  than yesterday humidity still up there  at 61 percent  but we've had some hail we've had some  passing showers  and i think that's going to continue  until later this evening when this storm  system  should begin to completely roll on out  of here so here's a look at your weather  headlines yes mother nature's weather  buffet gonna be a nice weekend ahead  we'll have the numbers and  more storms possible next week that's  the eight news now eight day forecast  coming up in a few minutes alex